[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
hier sind wir wieder Marco Kasimir und
Toni Heyer willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland heute mit einem Fall von dem
die meisten von euch ganz sicher schon
mal gehört haben dem Mord an Rivers Dean
Camp und wenn ihr jetzt denkt nee davon
habe ich noch nicht gehört dann liegt
das wahrscheinlich daran dass der Mann
der für den Mord verurteilt wurde noch
viel berühmter ist Oskar pistories
richtig in der Nacht zum Valentinstag
der des 14 Februar 2013 tötet der
weltberühmte Sprinter und Medien Star
Oskar pistories seine Freundin das
29-Jährige Fotomodell Rivas den Kampf
mit mehreren Schüssen und zwar im Bad
seines Hauses in Prätoria in Südafrika
pistories wird daraufhin verhaftet und
schließlich zu 15 Jahren Freiheitsentzug
verurteilt jo danke Mirko das war es
dann auch schon für heute
natürlich nicht die ganze Sache ist
selbstverständlich viel komplizierter
und auch viel interessanter sonst hätten
wir sie uns ja auch nicht heute
ausgesucht wobei ja eigentlich erstmal
alles klar scheint ne der Verdächtige
ist am Tatort das Opfer wurde eindeutig
erschossen und die Spuren passen sieht
somit also nicht nach einer schwierigen
Ermittlung aus ja aber andererseits gibt
es keine Zeugen ein paar Sachen passen
nicht so richtig zusammen und die Spuren
können durchaus unterschiedlich
interpretiert werden also Mirko schauen
wir uns das mal genauer an ne februar
2013 Revers dienen kann und Oskar
pistories sind seit einigen Monaten ein
paar sie ist ein erfolgreiches Fotomodel
und er ist ein Weltstar dessen
sportliche Erfolge die Menschen
begeistern und dessen Lebensgeschichte
vielen Hoffnung gibt und jeden
beeindruckt Oskar pistories wurde mit
einer Fehlbildung geboren und im Alter
von elf Monaten mussten ihm die Beine
unterhalb der Knie apportiert werden
2004 da ist er gerade 17 Jahre alt da
gewann er die Goldmedaille über 200
Meter bei dem Paralympics in Athen 2012
startet er als erster beidseitig
beinamputierte Athlet bei den
Olympischen Sommerspielen für die 4 x
400 Meter Staffel sein Team erreicht
Platz 7 eigentlich wollte er schon 2008
in Peking an der Olympiade teilnehmen
Kritiker waren aber der Meinung dass
seine in Deutschland angefertigten
spezialprothesen ihm einen Vorteil
gegenüber Athleten ohne Behinderung
verschaffen würden also da will ich
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so tief
einsteigen da kann jeder seine Meinung
zu haben ich würde sagen es ist nicht
unsere Aufgabe das zu klären das sollten
wir den Experten und vor allem dem Sport
Stammtisch überlassen diese Diskussion
auf jeden Fall letztlich verpasst der
2008 ohnehin die Qualifikation und 2012
da ist er dann dabei und Oskar Pistorius
ist ein Star auch Revers den Campus sehr
erfolgreich nicht nur als Model sie hat
Rechtswissenschaften studiert ist medial
sehr aktiv und plant schon die Zeit nach
der Modelkarriere vielleicht im TV oder
Kino eine kluge und schöne Frau und
definitiv ein Traumpaar auch oder gerade
in der Öffentlichkeit da wird viel über
Social Media öffentlich herumgeturtelt
sogar noch wenige Stunden bevor diese
Tragödie passiert ist dieser Mord
es scheint also alles bestens und der 14
Februar 2013 ihr erster gemeinsamer
Valentinstag der hätte ein Traum werden
sollen aber er wird ein Albtraum
am Vorabend des Valentinstages 2013 sind
Reaver und Oscar zusammen in Pistorius
houseed-communities silverboards in
Pretoria befindet das ist ein
abgeriegeltes und bewachtes Wohnviertel
für eher reiche Leute diese Viertel sind
in Südafrika extrem beliebt denn das
Land gehört zu den gefährlichsten Orten
auf der Welt aufgrund der Geschichte des
Landes der jahrzehntelangen Herrschaft
der Apartheid-Regierung gibt es immer
noch erhebliche soziale Ungleichheiten
und Spannungen zwischen verschiedenen
Bevölkerungsgruppen
weshalb Raub Einbruch und auch Mord
leider so muss man es sagen fast schon
ganz alltägliche Delikte sind
gegen 31 nachts hören die Nachbarn laute
Stimmen und Gepolter aus pistories Haus
es scheint ein Streit zwischen den
eigentlich so verliebten zu toben die
Nachbarn beschweren sich beim
Sicherheitsdienst aber dann kehrt doch
ganz schnell wieder Ruhe ein und dann
knapp zwei Stunden später um 3 Uhr
knallen und vermittelt Schüsse durch die
Wohnanlage alle Nachbarn sind wach die
Polizei wird alarmiert in kürzester Zeit
ist die Gegend in Flackern des Blaulicht
getaucht sondern halten der Polizei und
Rettungswagen Brettern die gehackten
Kieswege des Reichenviertel entlang im
Schlepptau schon die Presse die über den
Polizeifunk Wind von der Schießerei
bekommen hat zu diesem Zeitpunkt an die
Nachbarn vermutlich noch nicht was
eigentlich wirklich vorgefallen ist man
denkt bestimmt dass es einen Einbruch
gegeben hat
dann allerdings tragen Bestatter einen
offensichtlich geführten Leichensack
heraus und Pistorius wird von der
Polizei weggebracht die Presse hat die
perfekte valentinstagsgeschichte egal
was hier passiert sein mag die
Klatschblätter wird es mit wilden
Spekulationen füllen pistories wird
gegen Mittag in ein Krankenhaus gebracht
wo ihm Blut für die Spurensicherung
abgenommen wird und Drogentests
durchgeführt werden dann am Nachmittag
macht pistory's seine erste Aussage und
schildert die Nacht so der und Riva
liegen sich nach einem netten
gemeinsamen Abend zur Nacht in das große
Bett des Schlafzimmers es ist sehr warm
und die Fenster zur Terrasse stehen weit
offen gegen 3 Uhr wacht Oskar Pistorius
unruhig auf
er legt aber nichts seine Beinprothesen
an da er kurze Wege im Haus auch ohne
sie zurücklegen kann er kann sich gut
und sicher ohne Prothesen und Krücken
bewegen er will so sagt er Riva nicht
wecken von der er annimmt dass sie ja
schlafend neben ihm liegt so sagt er
zumindest ja so sagt er zumindest er
lässt also auch das Licht aus und geht
zur Terrassentür wollt leise den
Standventilator nach drin schließt
vorsichtig die Tür und den Vorhang da
hörte es aus Richtung des Bades poltern
und klappern aus Kap histories vermutet
einen Einbrecher der über das Badezimmer
oder die angrenzende Toilette in das
Haus einsteigen will
er will sofort handeln und greift sich
die 9mm Pistole die immer im
Nachtschrank auf seiner Seite des Bettes
liegt dann bewegt er sich zum Bad dort
fordert er den vermuteten Einbrecher
hinter der verschlossenen Toilettentür
mehrfach auf das Haus zu verlassen
es rumort aber weiter und angeblich
kommt auch keine Antwort von der Person
hinter der Tür
pistories verliert die Nerven und feuert
viermal durch die geschlossene Tür
jemand schreit und es klingt nicht nach
einem Fremden Einbrecher es sind die
Schreie von Riva die Toilettentür ist
verriegelt ohne seine Prothesen kann er
nicht genug Kraft aufbringen um die Tür
aufzustoßen er arbeitet sich also zurück
ins Schlafzimmer schaltet das Licht an
liegt eilig die Prothesen an dann
versucht er die Tür der Toilette
aufzudrücken während er Riva schwer
atmen hat aber die Tür gibt nicht nach
also zurück ins Schlafzimmer dort steht
ein cricketschläger aus Hartholz in der
Ecke mit diesem zertrümmert er
schließlich die Tür zum Bad und sieht
seine Freundin Blut überströmt und
heucheln neben der Kloschüssel liegen
Tutorials hebt sie vom Boden auf und
trägt sie hinunter ins Foyer des Hauses
dort versucht er Riva wiederzubeleben
vergeblich auch die Rettungssanitäter
die schon wenige Minuten nach den
Schüssen eintreffen können nicht helfen
dazu hat sicher auch die verwendete
Munition beigetragen
deformationsgeschosse klingt ein
bisschen wie aus einem Comic aber diese
Geschosse haben einen besonders perfiden
Effekt sie sind auf maximale Zerstörung
ausgelegt da sie im Inneren des Körpers
auf Pilzen und sich in unzählige
Fragmente zerlegen und damit wesentlich
schwerere Verwundungen als normale
Kugeln anrichten im Krieg ist solche
Munition laut Hager Land kriegsordnung
verboten sie fällt unter das Verbot von
Waffen geschossen oder Stoffen die
geeignet sind unnötige Leiden zu
verursachen
solche Geschosse führen jedenfalls zu
extremen Verletzungen und
Verstümmelungen und von Oskar pistorias
vier Schüssen treffen drei
Riva stirbt gegen 4 Uhr am Morgen ihres
ersten gemeinsamen Valentinstags
aber Mirko Oscar Pistorius hat Polizei
und Rettungswagen doch gar nicht gerufen
oder
ja so ganz klar ist das alles eben nicht
auch mit der genauen zeitlichen Abfolge
und ob Reaver wie es in manchen
Zeitungen steht in seinen Armen oder
unter den Händen der Sanitäter stirbt
sicher ist dass Oskar anfangs nicht die
Polizei ruft sondern den
Sicherheitsdienst des Geländes und
seinen Vater und seine Schwester der
sagt er dass er einen schrecklichen
Fehler gemacht und Riva angeschossen
habe weil er sie für einen Einbrecher
hielt also dieselbe Geschichte die ja
auch der Polizei erzählt und vor Gericht
vertritt richtig pistories wird
angeklagt schon am 4 juni 2013 soll der
Prozess beginnen am 19 August beginnt er
tatsächlich wird aber nach einer
Anhörung auf März 2014 verschoben und ab
dem dritten märz steht pistories dann
wirklich vor Gericht angeklagt das
Mordes an seiner Freundin Riva Stinker
die Anklage hat eine ganz andere Version
des Geschehens als der Angeklagte in der
Beziehung zwischen Riva und Oskar
kriselt es obwohl beide erst seit drei
Monaten fest zusammen sind oskar ist
extrem eifersüchtig fängt an Riva und
ihre Freunde zu überwachen will immer
alles wissen und fühlt sich von der
Souveränität Reavers zurückgesetzt zumal
es bei ihm selbst gerade nicht so
richtig gut läuft zu viel Medienrummel
zu wenig es gibt häufig Streit
eine Nachricht von Riva taucht auf
geschrieben wenige Wochen vor ihrem Tod
nach einem Streit manchmal machst du mir
Angst schreibt sie und auch in dieser
Nacht kommt es zum Streit wie war sei
ins Bad geflohen und Oskar Pistorius
habe in tödlicher Wut die Schüsse
abgefeuert
eine große Rolle spielt im Prozess die
Frage ob er alle Schüsse kurz
hintereinander abgegeben hat oder ob
nach dem ersten Schuss Zeit verging das
ist deshalb wichtig weil er dann die
Zeit gehabt hätte sich über die
Konsequenzen dessen was er tut Gedanken
zu machen und zu überprüfen auf wen hat
er überhaupt wirklich schießt aber
Pistorius sagt ich hatte Angst dass
jemand anfangen würde zu schießen
ich hörte ein Geräusch aus dem inner der
Toilette ich mich versah hatte ich vier
Schüsse auf die Tür abgefeuert ich hatte
einen Klingeln in den Ohren ja aber eine
Nachbarin will dagegen gehört haben dass
nach dem ersten Schuss Stille eintrat
auch ein Experte sagt dass es eine Pause
gegeben haben müsse der erste Schuss
habe Revers steencamp in die Hüfte
getroffen daraufhin sei sie gestürzt und
der zweite Schuss der habe sie dann
verfehlt der dritte und der vierte
Schuss treffen sie in Arm und Kopf
hätte pistorie ist viel mal kurz
hintereinander abgedrückt hätten die
Treffer im selben Bereich Ihres Körpers
liegen müssen als Oskar Pistorius klar
wird was er gerade im wutrausch
angestellt hat zertrümmert er die Tür
und versucht seine sterbende Freundin
noch zu retten
vergeblich und er findet sofort eine
Alternative Geschichte von einem
vermeintlichen Einbrecher die ihn
entlasten soll also wieder einmal die
alte schreckliche Story von einem
besitzergreifenden aufbrausenden
unkontrollierten Mann der seine Freundin
oder Frau tötet der Klassiker zynisch
gesagt die normale Version eines
frauenmordes eines femizids tja das ist
was die Staatsanwaltschaft ihm vorwirft
dem widerspricht aber wie ihm seine Tat
augenscheinlich zugesetzt hat mehrere
Zusammenbrüche vor Gericht gerade wenn
es darum ging wie er seine Freunde
zugerichtet hat und klar auch das früher
Geständnis ein Geständnis das genau zu
den Indizien passt wobei es natürlich
einigen Interpretationsspielraum bei
diesen Indizien gibt und weder die eine
noch die andere Version hundertprozentig
ausgeschlossen werden kann
aber toni ist dir was aufgefallen
ja du willst wahrscheinlich darauf
hinaus dass es nicht die Wahl zwischen
schuldig und unschuldig ist oder genau
er hat in jedem Fall einen Menschen
durch eine verschlossene Tür erschossen
es geht also nicht um die Frage was Mauz
bzw Totschlag oder war es Notwehr gegen
einen Einbrecher es war in jedem Fall
mindestens Totschlag die wichtigen
ungeklärten Fragen sind nur auf wen er
zu schießen glaubte und ob er die
betreffende Person wirklich töten wollte
Pistorius sagt er habe die Möglichkeit
dass er die Person hinter der Tür töten
könnte gar nicht in Betracht gezogen
okay krasse Aussage wenn man Munition
verwendet die keinen anderen Zweck hat
als möglichst schnell und effektiv zu
töten oder mindestens maximalen Schaden
anzurichten dass er überhaupt auf
jemanden geschossen habe der Ihnen in
diesem Moment gar nicht direkt
das erklärt pistories mit seiner Angst
Südafrika ist wie gesagt ein extrem
gewalttätiges Land reiche Menschen
insbesondere weiße reiche Menschen leben
praktisch in Festungen haben Alarmknöpfe
am Bett oder wie pistories eine Waffe im
Nachtschrank und jeder kennt die
Geschichten über Morde und in Mord
endende Einbrüche also ja das ist nicht
komplett unglaubwürdig das Gericht hat
jedenfalls Zweifel an pistorius-version
der Geschichte kann jedoch weder eine
Tötungsabsicht nachweisen noch endgültig
klären ob er wirklich glaubte auf einen
Einbrecher zu schießen
am 11 und 12 September 2014 wird das
Urteil verkündet fünf Jahre Haft wegen
fahrlässiger Tötung und dazu kommen noch
drei Jahre auf Bewährung für ein anderes
Vergehen
fahrlässiges Verhalten im Umgang mit
einer Schusswaffe wenige Wochen vorher
hatte er in einem Restaurant mit einer
Pistole hantiert und dabei versehentlich
ein Schuss ausgelöst weißt du woran ich
dabei denken musste an diesen berühmten
aber fürchterlichen Spruch von Leuten
vor allem US-Amerikanern die für freien
Waffen verkauft sind und sagen ganz
don't kill people people kill people
also auf Deutsch Waffen töten keine
Menschen
töten Menschen genau und das stimmt
natürlich in gewisser Weise aber
eigentlich müsste es ja heißen Waffen
töten keine Menschen
mit Waffen töten Menschen für mich ist
dieser Spruch jedenfalls eher ein gutes
Argument dafür Menschen also wir reden
jetzt von privat Personen um Himmels
Willen keine Waffen in die Hand zu
drücken aber Toni dieses Urteil wegen
fahrlässiger Tötung das ist ja noch
nicht das Ende der Geschichte nein die
Staatsanwaltschaft geht nämlich in
Berufung die wird auch zugelassen und ab
dem 13 märz 2015 steht pistories wieder
vor Gericht und diesmal erkennt das
Gericht auf Mord mit verminderter
Tötungsabsicht an das entspricht etwa
dem Totschlag im deutschen Strafrecht im
drohen nun 15 Jahre Haft die jedoch
wegen mildernder Umstände auf sechs
Jahre herabgesetzt werden und wichtig
dabei ist er wird nicht wegen Mordes bzw
Totschlag sein Rivers den Kampf
verurteilt sondern wegen Mordes an naja
wer auch immer sich seiner Meinung nach
hinter dieser Badezimmertür befunden
hatte er musste wissen dass er diese
Person mit seinen Schüssen töten würde
naja aber so vorsätzlich da werden doch
sechs Jahre da käme er wirklich
eigentlich ganz gut davon ne zu gut nach
Meinung südafrikanischen
Verfassungsgerichts 2017 wird die
Haftstrafe auf 15 Jahre erhöht das
mindeststrafmaß für eine solche Tat
oskar pistories ist immer noch in Haft
Anträge auf Entlassung auf Bewährung
wurden mehrfach abgelehnt zuletzt am 31
März 2023 die reguläre haffzeit endet
2031 ein Fall der Südafrika und die
ganze Welt bewegt hat die Geschichte
eines gefallenen Helden
und eigentlich ist es auch echt daneben
wieder mal dreht sich alles um den Typen
den Mörder den Täter und sein Opfer
dieses Gefühl nur Statistin am Rande ist
doch eigentlich scheiße aber ich meine
wir machen das ja auch nicht anders
vielleicht blöd aber wie du schon sagst
es ist halt diese faszinierende
Geschichte eines Mannes der
bewundernswert ist erreicht hat ein Star
ein Hoffnungsträger der dann zum Mörder
wurde das ist das was uns fasziniert
gruselt auch interessiert und Fragen
aufwirft was den Fall naja ebenso
spannend macht ändert aber trotzdem
nichts dran dass das Opfer komplett
vergessen wird ja dass ein Mensch
sinnlos und schrecklich starb dass seine
Mutter ihre Tochter verloren hat und
niemals darüber hinwegkommen wird das
ist die Tragödie aber die Sensation ist
der Täter
tja traurig aber wahr und damit sind wir
am Ende unsere heutigen Folge danke wie
immer fürs zuhören und schön dass ihr
dabei wart wir hoffen ihr bleibt uns
treu empfiehlt uns weiter und lasst eine
Bewertung auf dem Plattform da bis bald
eure Toni und euer Mirko die Geschichte
von Rivas Dean Camp und Oskar pistories
haben wir unter anderem erzählt anhand
von Artikeln bei nbc.com
bbc.com
und der International Business times
Script und Postproduktion Wake world
Studios München